when I went through the surgery for
moyamoya I didn't tell anyone
[Music]
it was a very difficult time for me
[Music]
I had to write down what would happen to
all my things if I were to die
I think when you're faced with your own
mortality you want to make sure that you
live your life how you wanted to live it
I just want to keep making the most
amazing music and showing people that
you know if I can do it anyone can do it
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Jennifer Lee but I'm better
known as Toki monster I am a music
producer and live for former DJ and all
the songs are composed by me electronic
music is the music producers world it is
what you can do to push the envelope
[Music]
my music is electronic
[Music]
[Applause]
but it has many organic sounds like a
piano or a violin
going a step further beyond that is
creating instruments out of non
instruments
so something that I like to do is use
field recordings I take a little
recorder around with me and real cord
different kinds of sounds that I like I
can use little bits of that to create
new sounds they do have a really
interesting tonality that is not common
in music this is my song roses Lauren it
is a track off my most recent album loon
Rouge
[Music]
with this track I did use a lot of Filth
recordings for the drum sounds I decided
to use a truck door rocks hitting each
other and a regular snare drum I layered
them all on top of each other
together we have and the great thing is
when you do stuff like that no one else
will have that sound no one else will
have a snare truck door rock sound in
their song there are unusual sounds
things that are not considered music I
recorded this wonderful Beach sound
that like weird bird chirping there is
something to me about creating an
environment in a song
it takes you somewhere else beyond just
the song and the melodies you're
actually removing someone from their
environment when putting them by the sea
putting them in nature
I was raised in Torrance California I
was born to an immigrant mother my
father passed away when I was very young
so for the most part I was raised by a
single mother who worked very hard to
kind of provide for me so I took piano
for about ten years my upbringing
introduced me to music though I don't
think my mom intended for me to become a
musician I remember discovering West
Coast hip-hop everything about it was
something that appealed to me a lot and
I flourished in that
I would start producing when Santry
college even though I loved hip-hop I
had no access to rappers when I was
starting out so the music started to
become hip-hop beats but with electronic
sounds in it no one had heard this style
of music that was so much hip-hop was so
for thinking and electronic I started
participating in other events with other
producers and I became a part of a scene
that itself could almost just be like a
rap beat the drums himself are just so
simple without anything else that's why
I find it percussion is very important
if you creeps movement even the pianos
the main thing is that there's movement
[Music]
that bass sound is very simple all it is
is one note
rhythm guitar the guitar lead
[Music]
they're not coming from a real guitar I
was going for a non realistic guitar
sound I made the songs like right after
my surgery it was one of the first songs
that I worked on
around ten years ago I started getting
migraines one doctor suggested that I
potentially could have a disease called
moyamoya the arteries on the left and
right side that supply blood to your
brain start to shrink and then so what
ends up happening is stroke aneurysm you
will die fast forward about ten years
later I had a strange incident where I
couldn't feel my left foot in the back
of my head I've always had that moyamoya
thing there by January of 2015 I had two
brain surgeries a week apart from each
other right after the surgery I was
tired and in pain but I was okay it was
the recovery process that was difficult
I would get stroke symptoms but I
couldn't feel entire left side of my
body and just out of nowhere I
completely lost my ability to talk and
to understand speech and I could no
longer communicate with anyone in one
thing that I noticed about this entire
process was I couldn't understand music
anymore it's nothing but noise like an
airplane flying in the sky I couldn't
understand music so there was no music
anymore that was very difficult for me
[Music]
eventually I noticed that the language
was getting a little better
day by day the soundtrack is coming back
all the music that you hear in the
elevator out of people's cars on TV all
these things were slowly creeping back
into my life then I was elated this is
what I have right now these are all from
the same take but I had to mix them all
differently because depending on what
note you say those frequencies would
jump out more when I went to open my
computer it's to be like okay this is a
time it's my time to shine I'm gonna try
making a new song it was awful it was
garbage it didn't sound good at all I
didn't know how to make music anymore
I figured if everything else came back
this would come back let's try recording
one of your leads for our song and see
if we can like breathe in some new life
good people think that I had to relearn
how to make music I didn't have to
relearn it I just had to wait for it to
come back I'll play like a couple bars
before it goes in fast-forward just like
a week or two weeks I was able to make
the very first song that ended up on my
most recent album cool that was great
another element of the song are these
little vocal samples they are not words
they don't mean anything it's just
effects
[Music]
[Applause]
it is having the beauty of a person's
voice without them distracting you with
words and these songs essentially make
themselves and even I'm surprised at the
end you know how they comes to be I was
like I had no idea that they're making a
song like this for me as a musician I
always want to innovate I don't want to
be making the same type of music as
everyone else because then why wouldn't
people need to listen to my music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after the brain surgery the one thing
that changed was my philosophical
approach once you're faced with the fact
that you might die you realize I don't
want to live my life for anyone else but
myself I want to be the kind of artist
that creates her own vision for herself
no matter what it is that I do and I
want to know that each day I live I feel
fulfilled
[Music]
you
[Music]